While there's never any shortage of shows
to binge on Netflix, the streaming service
also boasts a massive, ever-changing selection
of movies.
But it's all too easy to take a chance on
a new film, only to realize how bad it is
halfway through.
"Hey guys"
"What?"
"What if the movie sucks?"
With that in mind, we rounded up a handful
of hidden gems on Netflix to make sure your
movie night is suck-free.
Movies like...
The Voices
Released in 2014, The Voices tells the tale
of a guy named Jerry, played by Ryan Reynolds,
who lives a simple but lonely life as a factory
worker.
His only real friends are his cat, his dog,
and his psychopathic urges.
It's a seriously dark, twisted comedy anchored
by Reynolds' performance as a troubled but
cheerful guy who's so out of touch with reality
that even he can't believe some of the stuff
he's doing.
Obviously, Ryan Reynolds isn't known for his
horror movies.
If you've seen the 2005 Amityville Horror
remake and find it hard to believe that Reynolds
could play both funny and a legitimate creep,
you should give The Voices a watch.
"You have the greatest hair, Tom.
In the back.
It's awesome."
Snow on Tha Bluff
Even though it's labeled as a documentary,
Snow on Tha Bluff is actually a "found-footage"
reality film that follows Curtis Snow, a real-life
armed robber.
After Snow steals a camera from some naive
college students, he hands it to a buddy and
tells him to start filming.
Even though it's not truly a documentary,
Snow on Tha Bluff gives the audience a chilling
look at the gritty reality of life on the
street from Snow's perspective.
While the footage is mostly dramatized, Curtis
Snow himself is very real and the situations
he faces are a daily reality for many.
The Invitation
It's hard to talk about The Invitation without
spoiling the best parts, so we'll leave it
at this: if there was ever a dinner party
that went downhill, it's this one.
Director Karyn Kusama loads the movie with
tension right from the start and builds the
drama in a way that leaves you guessing right
along with the characters.
With great, low-key performances from Michiel
Huisman and Logan Marshall-Green, The Invitation
is a swan dive into paranoia.
It's also a welcome change of pace for Kusama,
whose previous films, Jennifer's Body and
Aeon Flux, weren't exactly gems themselves,
hidden or otherwise.
Spectral
Sci-fi thrillers with style are hard to come
by.
If that's your kind of thing, chances are
you've seen all the good ones—and way too
many bad ones—which makes Spectral even
more of a treat.
Following a team of U.S. Special Forces who
stumble across a mysterious new enemy while
on assignment in Moldova, Spectral jacks the
action into the stratosphere with lightning-quick
combat scenes and several nail-biting moments
of true terror.
Spectral isn't perfect, but it delivers what
it promises: a bunch of dudes fighting for
their lives against an otherworldly threat.
Stick it on, crank up the volume, and enjoy
the ride.
The Midnight Meat Train
Based on a short story by horror legend Clive
Barker, The Midnight Meat Train is straightforward
and extremely violent.
It follows a struggling photographer, played
by Bradley Cooper, who uncovers some weird
goings-on in a New York subway station late
at night.
Convinced there's a killer on the loose even
though nobody else believes him, he decides
to dig deeper on his own, and finds himself
drawn into an underground world darker than
he could have imagined.
Unfortunately, some changes at Lionsgate during
the movie's release all but guaranteed that
nobody would see the film.
According to Barker, the studio opted to give
The Midnight Meat Train a very limited release
in second-rate theaters in favor of promoting
their other titles, like The Strangers, released
the same year.
The result?
The $15 million picture brought back only
$83,000 and then quietly drifted away into
obscurity.
Queue it up on Netflix and give it the attention
it deserves, because this is honestly one
of the best thrillers on the service right
now.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!